hey what's up guys my name is echono and
hypixel made a new map um
and it is actually called creep survival
2 okay so hypixel for those of you who
do not know he made the walls too and
obviously the original the walls as well
um and that's like i've got like a
series going on around that so um so
yeah he's probably my favorite map uh
creator because um he's like he's pretty
much the only guy i know who actually
consistently makes like amazing maps
so um
so yeah quick note okay first of all
this texture pack is uh bundled with the
actual map so you have to actually wear
this texture back while you're um while
you're playing this map and also you
actually need the latest snapshot i'm
using 12w 42b this does not work with
minecraft 1.3.2 and you'll see why in a
minute i'll show you um
we'll jump in like real quick you'll see
that you spawn here and then suddenly
you get teleported here if you do not
have the latest minecraft snapshot you
will not get teleported into this little
rocky area okay so make sure you
download the latest snapshot otherwise
you will not be able to play it the link
to this map will obviously be in the
description as normal okay so
a single player map press to start
let's roll
did i press that
um
oh it's right click since when is it
right click i thought it was always left
click maybe i'm just going crazy all
right so oh
all right that's first of all some um
pretty loud explosions and we got a lot
of really good stuff so i mean
it must be um
it's in damages
it must be really um let's just put this
all on
this that's iron with blast protection
this must be really dangerous there's a
lot of creepers to be expected
and i'm kind of scared here
all right
turn the music up sound down a bit just
because there's going to be a lot of
explosions going on i'm guessing all
right
so what's the deal anyway we can go here
oh i just triggered the
i just triggered both of them
oh hang on
music's a bit too loud
those arrows
i've got it on peaceful
make sure you don't put on peaceful
oh wow
holy crap
make sure to have it on peaceful
hopefully i didn't ruin the map too much
actually killed him
okay i'm guessing i just run from these
guys i'm not gonna have time to um
i don't have time to attend to all of
their
wounds oh why are they glowing was that
what does that mean oh look at my health
holy crap oh gunpowder
i'm gonna help um creep a coin
using merchants for special items hmm
okay
let's um
shrink this get some health
uh instant damage is what we've also got
all right
again i kind of have to trigger this in
order to
get through to the next section
yeah yeah
oh do they like
this is unbelievable
oh god i'm gonna die
okay
well i died
but i respawned here so this could take
a this could take a while
did i put it to
normal
all right
wow this is um this is insane
all right well i've got some damage
actually
there's so many of them as well oh
this is actually like ridiculously hard
because there's so many of them and um
i guess i can like chuck them back a bit
make sure maybe if they explode
well he's dead
maybe i can enchant something as well
i can get one of them to explode yeah
they'll all die
all right
let's gather all these gun pouches in
case it'll come in handy
we've got like we've got tons if i had
sand as well i can make so much tnt
right now all right what's in here
more creepy coins
i didn't even notice that
to be honest did not even notice
all right same tactic as before right
oh i can't even like
oh god
all right
so
i don't know what the creep is like when
they're covered in that stuff i don't
know what it means when they're like
covered in that okay here we go so here
i should be able to buy some stuff
random ultimate armor random ultimate
potion
wow
all right not sure what's going on so
oh that's pretty good
i think i'll have to take that
weapons what can you give me knock back
two sharpness one
and you can you just give me oh yeah
definitely i've got so much
just take 11 steak right now
gold leggings whilst protection three
this is free to to do
take it it is
visibly tense alone is 10 regeneration
10 vanishing avoid creepers that's good
i'll pick up the weapon might as well
it's better than this one anyway still
iron though
but it's enchanted so um we're all good
all right
oh well hang on let me put on
plus protection three here
oh that's just an artifact
wow that that drained quite a bit of my
health actually
might drink this in the future if
there's a lot of them i'll probably
drink that potion
to avoid them yeah that must mean that
he's like super bowed or something
i've got knocked back though
oh no
how many shots does it take to kill him
quite a lot
all right sweet
so i'm guessing this is gonna be one of
those
points where i'm just gonna have to
drink this because um
i'm just drinking it
oh probably no point in drinking it at
all
okay well i'm clearly dead here okay all
righty this is insanely difficult if
anyone can do this on normal difficulty
without dying
make a video and link it to me i'll um
i'll i'll watch it
oh my god
dude they run so fast as well look at
him
so much faded
i need to be able to enhance something
with this
oh wow
dude there's so many of them
okay so good when they explode i'll
probably get one of them to explode yeah
there we go
might be a better tactic
how am i gonna do this dude look how
many there are
this is insane
all right
i gotta gotta complete this map because
there's a new episode of dexter waiting
for me to watch
um
season seven episode four
they're so good
as soon as i kill all these damn
creepers
does blocking actually do anything
against creepers
doubt it
all right there's sort of
less and less of them i might just have
to
run
oh i'm out like out of food as well oh
crap crap crap okay food
all right
yes crave a coin that's so good
all right not even gonna bother
collecting that crap i don't need it
right now
all
right i'm already got that
i guess i'll
play your game again
i've already been here
it feels like i've already been here
i don't think i have that right
oh i almost exploded
okay
geronimo
good thing that was water then okay
going into the depth of the depths of
this
map
these are they are so ex they're so
explosive these creepers
okay that's dead oh no we got caught in
there
this creep is not exploding that much oh
all right um wait some of that got to
reject some help
oh wow he's right here
oh here we go
all right
this is this is very bad this place
yeah
there they are it's just the one button
i think the best tactic is to leave no
it's not
jj creep is jj
ah
i just got caught in string well i'm
dead again so again anyone anyone does
this without dying you let me know
not even kidding at this point this is
stupid
ah
they just keep dropping from the sky man
what am i supposed to do
all right
nope they're still dropping
about time get me out of here
good luck high pixel oh great
these invisible creepers
oh crap
i'm just running
when will this end
okay
i think i think we made it
oh
look at this
i can sleep
at night
thank you by hypixel
thank you for playing creeper dungeon a
small map to celebrate high pixels 50
000 subscribers milestone
well congrats bro
it's a lot of subscribers you got there
wow now this this was a this wasn't a
really nice map like i did do this
ending this ending blows my mind
such a good ending like look at this
it's like a little house and you can't
even get out of it but
wow
this reminds me of something like weird
it's oh god
really nice map guys check it out again
if anyone
everyone can do this without dying you
uh you post a video you link it to me
and uh
and we'll see
all right ladder guys
you